herz mit der familie ritalin missbrauch
als sie um rückmeldung erinnere was wie
merker freuen und auf einige möchte es
gerne ego und erste eigentlich geht auf
kritik
kritisch fabienne schrieb zum beispiel
klar gibt es viele missbrauchsfälle was
ritalin und co anbelangt ich finde es
aber schade dass es hier vor allem aus
einem negativen blickwinkel betrachtet
wird die personen die mit adhs oder
narkolepsie diagnostiziert wurden hilft
ritalin und erleichtert ihnen den alltag
wäre schön wenn ich nur die negativen
aspekte sondern auch dies klar
kommuniziert werden polish gibt in
diesem film während die sichtweite eines
wirklich betroffenen menschen oder
zumindest ein hinweis darauf wie
methylphenidat bei menschen mit adhs
wirkt diese differenzierung hätte ich
mir gewünscht
ich hatte kritik durchaus
nachvollziehbar inzwischen über rheuma
sich adhs oder
krankheit die er hervor und als
kampfhund persönlich nehme ritalin ich
kenne die vorteile hat und darum wurde
mit der reportage nicht wie ich die
vorteile für diese tatsache dass es
nicht geht wo die medikamentenmissbrauch
delete bis zum teil überhaupt nicht was
die medikamente für konsequenz und
folgen wenn sie missbraucht darum gott
sieht ihre reportage explizit um
missbrauch und sinnvoll ist bewusst
sieht schaffen und ich glaube mehrheit
der focus mit platz gesetzt will sich
schon so ritalin wird häufiger
missbraucht aus man eigentlich denkt und
dass spielplätze haben aber wieder in
den kommentaren und reportagen zum
beispiel rafael hat beschreibt ich nehme
alle paar monate ritalin maximal eine
woche in stressigen situationen ortete
band - sie besteht vor allem bei der
leistungsorientierten unis wieder hsg
oder der oma ist das ein wachsendes
problem
meine recherche henrys mammitzsch
rebecca und jetzt bezirk das aber schon
vor ihrer 14 15 jährige tochter erst
kürzlich eingeführt worden ist wieder
dritter die glut worte nicht mehr infos
hat sie mit war gab es zeigt einfach sf
bieswang gesellschaft ist und ich glaube
es bewusst sie gar was passiert wenn es
missbraucht
direktor patissia hast du das gefühl
dass du durch den konsum von ritalin die
vorteile gegenüber seinen mitschülern
die schülerinnen und mit studenten und
studentinnen erlangt hat er bisher noch
gedruckt und sie haben anspruch nehmen
oder zurückgeschickt
das ist ein vorteil oder so erlangt
haben
kommentar das lied nicht verstanden hand
das ist mir schon aber es braucht halt
also ich würde sagen
/ wenige sätze daraus gemacht
dass ich mich
selber und
die andere lied ich habe auch weil
ja also das ist so nicht fallen
dennis frohn zwar wäre eine strengere
regulation von ritalin oder ähnlichen
medikamenten effektiv und den missbrauch
einzuschränken
ich meine vorstellung ist schwierig wenn
man ritalin und co mit strengen
reglementierung wenn man das mitmachen
würden frauen der großteil von der lieth
bestrafte wo ein korrekt mit um gott und
das ist dass sie mit
ads mit der schlafkrankheit und
lud wo das war missbrauch die räume
irgendwie rang das medikament habe
drogen auf der straße dem schwarzmarkt
übers internet oder was auch immer nun
bin ich da und so setzen wir für das
bringt wenn man träger liga strenge wird
machen und ob es den rückbau die
richtige trifft wichtig ist aber dass
man es bewusst geschafft viel konsequenz
sei für den missbrauch was passiere wenn
man so medikament missbraucht gerne mal
wieder zum quietschen ist wieder endlich
schreibt leute wenn wir ein studium
nicht ohne drogen schafft dann läuft es
einfach ortete matthias schreibt hallo
liebes slf team ich hätte nicht gedacht
dass so verbreitet ist wenn das jemand
so leistungssteigerung nimmt ist es dann
nicht eine beförderung für den mensch
wenn es so etwas nehmen muss um seine
leistung zu haben lebe matthias g froh
kann ich mir auch schon gestellt und so
gibt sich die antwort zu aber ich habe
mir vorstelle es gibt sicher einige lüth
wo ritalin missbrauchen um ihren eigenen
ansprüche werks werte wie sehr
hat sich selber
hang zum perfektionismus kann ich
vermisst habe mosley aber das gesicht
olivo probiere es
ging also nicht persönlich
leistungsdruck heiser und leistungsdruck
vom studium vom schaffen oder aber gott
vor beiden würde beides unter einen hut
zu bringen da ganz leicht ixs rookies
oder gesellschaft davon auch gut
vorstellen das ist für mich
und das noch dazu führt dass sein lied
aber probieren mit entega mittels push
aber die experten
im schnitt geschickt oder intelligente
du hast es hat einfach denn sozusagen
länger über durch die über längere zeit
konzentrieren
und wenn es nur noch ums büro heute
habe ich einen guten job
italien ist der brauch einen drucker
stellt sich die frage warum diese
konsumenten auto fahren dürfen ein f
konsument aber nicht gemeinsam
schmunzler
glaubte manchmal ganz klar
differenzieren zwischen legalen gebrauch
und missbrauch
wenn der polit alfred
den bruch des niveaus droge sondern muss
man die kraft und das ist genau ganz
andere fachpersonen zum beispiel wissen
trophy das adhs betroffene besser auto
fahren wenn die ritalin analyse aber
konzentriert und fokussierter sie oft
stress und einige leute ablenken also
wenn sie aber keine medikamente also es
ist ja eigentlich das klinikum mit
medikament wenn sie coacht sie
blüht und die medikamente an der zeit
dann gibt's noch mal kritik gefallen ist
und zwar
momentan das schwebt das methylphenidat
kein hai als euphorie verursacht ist
quatsch als frage der dosis und
applikations und auto stimmen man
schreibt an vitamin ist auch nicht
euphorisch bei 30 milligramm jedoch bei
100 milligramm und mehr dann kommt ihr
euch vor die vitrinen koloss tendenziell
kreispolizei sms ganze aus medizinischen
gründen nimmt oder leicht steigen wie
der normale dosis
dass wir die erste linie auf der
wirklichkeit dafür hat die vielleicht
weiß oder besser mir so formuliert es
formuliert damit keine missverstanden
ist geht wie ritalin und co
wenn es über bord mit dass jährige
halluzinationen auslösen
denn zum schluss gibt es
rabatt gibt neun könnte man das darüber
berichten dass diese medikamente auch
für menschen mit adhs gefährlich sind
was bei einer dauerhaften einnahme dem
gehirn passiert oder passieren kann ich
habe adhs und wie das nicht nehmen damit
ich nicht verrückt werde davon eher für
die republik und da kommt liegt wo adac
und ritalin concerta oder annahmen und
derart mies wie viel zeug wollte sich
ihr acht unterschiedliche als glühten
sagte er egal kein ritalin da geht es
liegt wohl sagen sie
haben
wir zum beispiel was uns von anderen
also persönlichkeitsveränderungen und
sich lange durch italien & co und
unrichtige lachen und wir richtig
fröhlich sie genau wird geheim ihre
experten zeugt das ist aber nicht
extrem wichtig dass man so nah wie
möglich an und
informieren